(Steve whispers indistinctly)
- [Interviewer] Do you
remember your childhood?
- Not really.
I got a boil on my nut sack
for sitting on an antique toy tractor.
- [Interviewer] I'm sorry, say that again.
- You know what a boil is?
- I do know what a boil is.
- I got one on my balls.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I had an old, like a farm all,
like the red tractor with things
that would lift up with
two wheels in the front,
and it had the paddles that would go.
This was an old one.
And something about that one,
I remember sitting on that seat
and Jesus has made it
clear throughout my life
in different times that he doesn't
want me farming the ground.
- [Interviewer] So, Steve,
tell me where you're from.
- I'm from, I spent the
last 14 years in Maine,
in Birchington, Maine,
that's where I was born.
At the age of two, we
moved to southern Illinois,
which is where I call home,
but I haven't been
actually home for 20 years.
- [Interviewer] You out here?
- I spent the last 14 years
in Maine, Birchington, Maine,
and I've only been here for
a year and a half, I'm sorry.
- [Interviewer] And
where do you stay here?
You live on the street, or you?
You're on the street?
- My family divorced,
it was very pain, it--.
- [Interviewer] How old were you?
- Five.
- [Interviewer] Five years old.
- Yeah, I mean, the most traumatic thing
about my childhood, so.
- [Steve] I'm sorry--.
- It sucked, it sucked, and then having
to go through the divorce.
And then after that, it was you know
I'd go stay with my father and
found out he's gonna beat me
with a belt all the time, so
then I go back to my mother.
I'm like, take the less
of the two evil, I guess.
- [Interviewer] Steve, so there's lots
of drugs and alcohol here in Skid Row,
are you involved in any of that?
- Yeah, I mean, since I got here,
I mean it's like things I need.
- [Interviewer] What drugs
are the ones you go to.
- When I first got here
I was a social drinker.
And that, that's interesting,
there's interesting stories behind that.
- [Interviewer] What are you using now?
- I'm just on some prescription meds
from a no fill pharmacy.
- [Steve] Prescription meds for what?
(Steve whispers indistinctly)
- I'm trying to get SSI.
And it's not trying, they
think I have a problem,
they just don't know,
they don't know exactly
whether or not I'll be able to
work full time or part time,
will I be able to handle
a full time work schedule?
That's a lot for somebody
that has a mental disability.
And is going through
periods of uncertainty.
- [Interviewer] What is your disability.
- I've been diagnosed before,
schizophrenic, chemically imbalanced.
- [Interviewer] At what
age did that happen?
- What did you say?
- [Interviewer] At what age
were you diagnosed with schizophrenia?
- 20.
- 20?
Have you ever been in a mental hospital?
(Steve laughing)
- After I've been able
to pick your family,
and, and, I'm pick your family,
you can't pick your family.
- [Interviewer] Steve, have
you ever been in a mental?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Hospital bed?
- I would've never went to the
mental health clinic period,
I would've roughed through it,
if it wasn't for my dear mother.
- [Interviewer] Steve, how old are you?
- I'm 40.
- 40.
- Mhmm.
- Where have you worked
throughout your life, have you had jobs?
- Yes.
- What jobs have you had?
- [Steve] I started out,
I had 19 different jobs
in Illinois, and I
worked in, from there on,
I've done oil field, I've done factory,
factory, factory, I've washed dishes,
I was a dishwasher a couple times.
I had a paper route.
I worked at McDonald's.
- [Interviewer] Which
was your favorite job?
- [Steve] I think cows,
for part of the summer.
I was what she needed, she needed,
she said, see that boy there,
she said he doesn't look very smart,
she said, do you wanna
work for me this summer
for minimum wage?
Feeding the cows and
mowing the grass and stuff.
I don't know how she knew that I would
be able to do the stuff
that needed to be done,
but without asking I just
started fixing the stuff.
- [Interviewer] Steve,
is there schizophrenia
in your family?
- So, everybody in my opinion,
is dealing with the same issues that I am.
And my uncle, John, he
just talks to himself.
(Steve laughs)
- [Interviewer] And your family is where?
- In Ohio.
- Do you speak to them?
- Near Cincinnati, yes.
On Facebook, more often than not
and it's been just them
and I for 20 years,
I've had no friends.
- [Interviewer] You have no friends?
- I haven't had, for the past 20 years,
it's been just family and I.
I have let my friends
go for bigger things.
More important things.
I went for three months this year
without even having an ejaculation.
And it was good.
It was good to not have to be
bothered by the ejaculation.
It was a good time.
It was bad to be bothered (indistinct),
it was good to have no ejaculation.
(Steve laughs)
That just proves that
God was involved somehow,
or it had something to do with my health,
and for three months I
didn't, he let me be in peace.
- [Interviewer] Does sexual
frustration irritate you?
Does it, is there a problem?
- Yeah, I struggle.
Will somebody else answer
the question for me?
(street music bumping)